[Norvig] The crux of the whole matter is doing the assignments.
There are 2 ways to do it.
We can deduce what assignment must be true--
that it must be the case that the Englishman is in a certain house.
Or we can just try different possibilities--
try to put the Englishman in house 1, then in house 2, then in house 3 and see what works.
You'd have to be very clever to figure out how to do all these deductions,
and I don't want to try to be that clever.
I want to see if I can get by with just trying all the possibilities,
make the computer do the work so I don't have to.
So let's approach that and let's say we're going to try all possibilities.
And so first we put the Englishman into house 1,
and later we'll try him in houses 2, 3, 4, and 5.
What about the Spaniard?
If the Englishman is in house 1, what possibilities should we try for the Spaniard?
Give me your best answer:
all the numbers; only 1; only 2; or 2, 3, 4, 5.